should we have seen black widow's tragic
ending coming all along did we all miss
the clues that foreshadowed her doom
keep watching to find out
born in soviet russia in 1984 the young
natasha romanov before she had that name
was purchased by the state from her
parents as an infant after it was
determined that she had great genetic
potential to serve their needs early
training helped natasha learn to obey
her masters and soon she would have her
first mission sent to the united states
as a child natasha and fellow assassin
and training elena belova would be
raised by adoptive parents a pair of
russian assassins named alexei and
molina this fake family unit would allow
the four to pose as a normal american
suburban household but when alexei and
molina completed their mission to steal
valuable us intelligence they were
discovered by shield the two russian
agents scooped up natasha and elena and
after a tense chase flew them out of the
country where they would be taken in by
alexei's superior general drakov a
ruthless russian leader who oversaw the
assassin training program known as the
red room
following their return to russia both
natasha and her sister elena were taken
to be trained as assassins in drakov's
sinister red room program during her
time in the red room natasha would
become one of the best killers in the
program with unmatched instincts and
marksmanship skills she would also
undergo rigorous psychological
programming and conditioning that would
essentially make her a slave to drakoff
but her training in the red room was
about more than just developing her
skills
doctors within the academy also gave
romanov a hysterectomy as they did to
all their assassins the hope was that
making the trainees unable to bear
children would ensure the total absence
of familial connections they have a
graduation ceremony
they sterilize you
romanov spent years acting as one of
russia's best assassins putting her on
the radar of american intelligence
agencies
eventually she would be targeted by nick
fury director of shield agent clint
barton later known as the hero hawkeye
would be assigned by fury to kill
natasha but over the course of his
mission barton instead convinced natasha
that she should defect to the united
states and join shield to earn the
agency's trust natasha's first mission
was to accompany barton to budapest and
kill her former teacher drakov romanov
hesitated at the prospect of bombing
drakov with his young child in tow but
she would ultimately give the order to
detonate apparently killing both drakoff
and antonia and officially earning
natasha a place as a shield agent
just like budapest all over again
you and i remember budapest very
differently
now in the employee of shield romanov
quickly became one of their best agents
and was sent on a number of critical
assignments during a 2009 extraction
mission in iran the winter soldier who
was once captain america's friend bucky
barnes ambushed her and killed her
target a nuclear scientist by firing
straight through romanov's stomach
though she learned little about the
winter soldier she knew enough to fear
him one person she knew a lot about was
the future avenger called iron man
after developing his first armored suits
tony stark came to the attention of
shield and was identified by fury as a
candidate for the avengers initiative
sent under cover under the name natalie
rushman natasha became stark's new
assistant assigned to keep tabs on the
budding hero romanov would eventually
reveal her identity as a shield agent
when stark came into conflict with ivan
venko and she aided him in stopping the
new armored villain however the
intelligence gathered by romanov on her
mission led fury to the conclusion that
stark was not suitable for his planned
super team deeming the billionaire
volatile self-obsessed and a poor team
player
textbook
narcissism
agreed
in 2012 nick fury gathered the
superheroes who would later be known as
the avengers romanov was sent to india
where she located bruce banner a
scientist with expertise in gamma
radiation who also happened to be the
human identity of the monster known as
the hulk convincing banner to help
shield locate the tesseract romanov got
banner aboard fury's helicarrier where
the two of them joined up with tony
stark thor and steve rogers aka captain
america
after capturing loki in germany however
the team began to fracture natasha was
able to trick loki into revealing his
plans to set off banner's transformation
into the hulk but was unable to prevent
it following an argument with fury and
the other heroes
banner did transform and the hulk
smashed his way through even the mighty
thor but when loki used the tesseract to
bring an invading alien army to earth
the team began to gel and natasha joined
them in the fight against the invading
chitari warriors after saving the day
romanov and the newly formed avengers
went their separate ways but they were
now the world's mightiest team of
superheroes
two years after the battle of new york
when georgia spatrock led a group of
terrorists in an attack on the shield
carrier lemurian star romanov retrieved
classified files while steve rogers took
out the enemy soldiers from that intel
romanov fury and rogers uncovered
evidence that shield was being secretly
run by the remnants of the terrorist
organization known as hydra and planned
on deploying three new helicarriers that
would allow them to take over the planet
romanov was faced with a fateful
decision if she exposed shield and hydra
to the public she'd also be exposing her
own past between her loyalty to fury and
her friendship with steve rogers however
it wasn't a hard choice
alongside rogers and new hero sam wilson
she helped defeat hydra and take down
shield for good
as a member of the avengers natasha
romanov went on a number of missions
with her new team and grew closer to her
teammate bruce banner natasha was the
one person capable of calming the hulk
when they needed him to revert to his
human form and their relationship slowly
began to blossom into a tentative
romance romanov would later be captured
by ultron but still proved instrumental
in his downfall after defeating ultron
and his robot army romanov attempted to
talk down the hulk over the phone while
he sat at the controls of a quinjet but
he ignored her pleas to return and flew
away to parts unknown
after ultron's defeat romanov found
herself an elder statesman on a new team
of avengers that now included one the
maximoff the android vision and sam
wilson the falcon romanov became a
leader on the team alongside rogers but
her position next to captain america
wouldn't last long following a mission
to lagos that resulted in the deaths of
civilians the avengers found themselves
at odds with the sokovia accords a
united nations resolution that would see
them become an officially sanctioned arm
of the world's governments romanov
advocated going along with the order but
rogers wilson maximoff and clint barton
split with the team and went on the run
with a battle of heroes on the horizon
it was romanov who recruited the
wakandan prince t'challa the black
panther to join them in stopping roger's
team but in a confrontation in germany
between the two factions romanov was
once again forced to choose between her
loyalty to rogers and barton and the
orders of her superiors forced to fight
barton hand-to-hand she was stopped by
wanda maximo but ultimately prevented
black panther from capturing rogers and
allowed him to escape when all was said
and done romanov left stark's team and
struck out on her own in defiance of the
law
romanov and her fellow fugitive avengers
soon found themselves being hunted by an
obsessed thaddeus ross the secretary of
defense alone and in hiding natasha
sought the help of old friends around
the globe including former shield agent
rick mason now operating as an
independent contractor but when she
received a mysterious package and became
the target of a shadowy assassin called
the taskmaster she began a new mission
to track down her adopted soviet sister
elena balova when they met in budapest
they realized that the red room was not
destroyed after all and that drakoff had
escaped romanov's assassination attempt
back when she first joined shield the
two sisters reunited with their parents
alexei and molina the former false
family worked together to stop drakoff
and take down the red room once and for
all to do that however they'd have to
get past the taskmaster who turned out
to be none other than dracop's daughter
as well as a new group of deadly black
widow agents whom they also hoped to
free from drakoff's mind control the
plan succeeded the red room was
destroyed and drakoff was killed by
bulova but it also put romanov back on
ross's radar he arrested her but she
escaped his custody with ease and went
on a mission to spring the others from
jail it's funny my whole life i didn't
think i had any family
turns out i got two
still a fugitive from the government and
still being hounded by ross at the start
of avengers infinity war romanov joined
rogers and wilson as an underground team
of heroes but in 2018 the interstellar
tyrant thanos sent his black order to
earth to steal the mine stone
one of the six infinity stones that was
required to wipe out half of all
existing life forms and which happened
to reside in vision's head with fellow
heroes iron man spider-man and dr
strange unexpectedly off-planet romanov
and her team stepped forward to help
defend their planet once again
reunited with bruce banner natasha began
assembling forces and making plans to
prevent thanos from retrieving the mind
stone
assisted by t'challa and his army of
wakandan warriors romanov would hide
vision in wakanda in a last-ditch effort
to defeat the overpowered titan several
avengers helped natasha and her forces
in their valiant defense vision but in
the end thanos simply proved too much
for them he took the mind stone and with
the snap of his fingers eliminated half
of all life in the universe
retreating to the avengers compound back
in upstate new york romanov rogers and
the other heroes who survived the snap
licked their wounds even taking their
revenge on thanos didn't help matters
the infinity stones had already been
destroyed and the damage was done
natasha took on a leadership position in
the avengers coordinating global
recovery efforts and assisting cosmic
heroes like rocket raccoon and captain
marva but five years after the snap the
pressures of leadership and the trauma
of loss were clearly starting to take
their toll so when scott lang aka
ant-man returned from the quantum realm
with a plan to change history natasha
gladly suited up as the black widow once
again to save the world of course to do
so she had to first travel to japan to
recruit her old friend clint barton who
had lost his entire family to the snap
and who had become a violent anti-hero
called ronan once they were back
together however romanoff and the rest
of the original avengers alongside
rocket and thanos's estranged daughter
nebula embarked on a mission to travel
back in time and reassemble the infinity
gauntlet in order to undo thanos heinous
act
upon journeying into the past the
remaining avengers split into smaller
teams to accomplish individual tasks
barton and romanov took the guardians of
the galaxy's spaceship to the planet of
vormir home of the hidden soulstone
there they found the ghostly form of the
red skull banished there since
attempting to wield the tesseract back
in world war ii who told the pair a grim
truth to obtain the soul stone one of
them had to die in one of the most
tragic moments in the entire mcu romanov
made the ultimate sacrifice giving her
life so that barton could be reunited
with his wife and son a final gift to
him for his years of friendship and
restitution for rescuing her from the
red room the debt she felt she owed
barton had at last been repaid for it
was he who had given her a new life as
the black widow a daughter a sister a
hero and an avenger forever
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]